with the Thanksgiving holiday coming up
and if a family member or family
together was to go see the film or watch
it at home what do you want them to take
away about family dynamics coming to
peace with who you are or you know you
can't you can't choose your family so
what what message do you want them to
come away with I mean honestly it's the
family's all you got and I you know in
in some ways that that's difficult to
deal with and complicated but in some
ways it's great like it doesn't matter
you know at the end of the day like you
know what job you have with money you
have like what all this stuff doesn't
matter like you have to tell your family
that you love them and they have told
you that they love you and it sounds
stupid and Patton Trey and ridiculous
but it's the point the friggin movie is
that they these people are unable to
talk to one another and they exist on
this you know they'll talk about a play
or about a you know foreign policy or
you know what would what wine one drinks
but they're unable to say they love each
other so that's the point of the movie
and you know the whole point is they at
the end they have to write anything for
you Cheryl I mean is there is there
something that you want people to take
away when they suppose someone went on
their own de theatre by themselves maybe
to get escaped the family dinner yeah
what would you want them to take away um
well to be a little more shallow let's
just want them to be entertained you
know it is in a perfect world they'd
come away going wow my family my family
is not so bad compared to them so so
just that sort of escape you know you go
to the movies did you watch somebody
else's life for an hour and a half and
you're like that was great and it like
will says you know you hope that they
come away you hope people come out
thinking I'm thankful for what I have
and I gotta love my family regardless
but but it I really hope they come out
going what we're not as red as in like
watching a reality show where you're
like that at least we're not down yeah
so that's what I hope for the world
haha
you